***
Wasser.
Erde.
Feuer.
Luft.
Der Avatar beherrscht
als Einziger alle diese Elemente.
Damit beugt "The Last Airbender"
so ziemlich jedes Naturgesetz.
Aber:
Wir zeigen euch heute
in krassen Live-Experimenten,
wie viel Wissenschaft
trotzdem in der Serie steckt.
*bedrohliche Musik*
Guten Tag zusammen, Jack Pop hier!
Ihr habt euch "Avatar" gewünscht,
und ihr bekommt ihn.
Und zwar in einer Doppelfolge.
Ich gebe es zu:
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass da so viel Physik drinsteckt.
Deswegen geht es in dieser Folge
nicht ohne unsere Physikerin Anne.
Es gibt nicht nur Science-Input,
sondern wir brauchen jemanden,
der uns die Fiktion erklärt.
Dafür haben wir uns
einen "Avatar"-Experten geholt.
Fabian hat nicht nur
einen YouTube-Kanal zu "Avatar".
Er ist auch
schon lange Teil unserer Community.
"Der Herr der Elemente"
begleitet ihn seit 15 Jahren so sehr,
dass er die Elemente
sogar auf der Haut verewigt hat.
Fabi, cool, dass du da bist
und die "Avatar"-Skills präsentierst.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
- Gern.
Gib uns mal eine Zusammenfassung.
Für alle,
die "Avatar" nicht gut kennen:
Was können die Bändiger,
und was müssen wir uns anschauen?
In der fiktiven Welt von "Avatar"
gibt es 4 Nationen bzw. Stämme.
Erdkönigreich, Luftnomaden,
Feuernation und Wasserstämme.
Nicht nur das.
Es gibt
innerhalb der Völker Menschen,
die über die Fähigkeit verfügen,
Wasser, Erde,
Feuer und Luft zu bändigen.
Okay, aber nur der Avatar
kann alle 4 Elemente beherrschen.
Genau.
Er ist auserwählt,
verbindet Menschen- und Geisterwelt.
Er kann alle Elemente bändigen
und mit Hilfe seiner Fähigkeit
die Balance aufrecht erhalten.
Okay, der Avatar
ist also super besonders.
Aber die Bändiger auch.
Du hast gesagt,
nicht alle Menschen können bändigen.
Die müssen
irgendwie an die Fähigkeiten kommen.
Wie kommen die da hin?
Es ist nicht so einfach.
Nehmen wir Katara als Beispiel.
Die 1. Bändigerin,
die uns vorgestellt wurde, ist sie.
Sie kann Wasser bändigen,
obwohl es vorher nie jemand konnte.
Das hat nichts mit Zauberei zu tun,
das nennt sich "Wasserbändigen".
Eine uralte Kunst unserer Vorfahren.
Bla, bla, bla.
Auf der anderen Seite erfahren wir,
dass der Feuerlord sich eine Frau
mit starker Blutlinie gesucht hat.
Aus der Verbindung kamen
2 wichtige Bändiger zum Vorschein,
was nach Genetik klingt.
Dazu passt auch, dass wir nie sahen,
wie ein Feuerbändiger
ins Erdkönigreich geboren wurde.
Wichtiger als die Vererbung
sind die spirituellen Energien.
Was die Bändiger brauchen,
um ihr Element zu wecken
oder weiter zu entwickeln.
Okay, also spielt
göttliche Fügung eine große Rolle.
Das heißt aber dann auch:
Sie müssen ihre Fähigkeit trainieren.
Ja, genau, wobei es
unterschiedliche Methoden gibt.
Angefangen bei Kampfkünsten
bis hin zur Meditation.
Deswegen gibt es
unterschiedlich starke Bändiger,
und Dinge,
die nur mächtige Bändiger können.
Okay, das klingt cool.
Wenn ihr euch fragt,
welcher Bändigungstyp ihr wärt,
welches Element
euch am ehesten stehen würde,
dann habe ich
einen Test in die Infobox gepackt.
Den habe ich auch gemacht,
und bei mir kam raus:
Ich bin Wasserbändiger.
Fabi, bei dir?
Luftbändiger.
Luftbändiger?
- 100%.
Dann ist das heute deine Folge.
Das besprechen wir nachher.
Aber bevor wir uns
die Elemente anschauen,
wollen wir mal klären,
wie das mit dem Bändigen
in echt funktionieren könnte.
Denn in der Serie ist es Fiktion.
Natürlich findet "Avatar"
in der fiktionalen Welt statt.
Aber beim Bändigen
gibt es Regeln und Gesetze,
weshalb ein Bändiger
nicht irgendwas anstellen kann.
Nach dem Motto:
"Magic that makes sense."
Okay.
Wie viel Sense das macht,
schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Und zwar Physikerin Anne.
Die hat mir versprochen,
dass wir vieles,
was wir in der Serie sehen,
wissenschaftlich herleiten können.
Anne, sag mir bitte:
Wenn ich
der nächste Avatar werden möchte,
was muss ich tun?
Du muss nur
Herr des Elektro-Magnetismus werden.
Damit lässt sich vieles erklären,
was wir in "Avatar" sehen.
Dabei geht es um elektrische
und magnetische Felder.
Es werden alle Stoffe
von Magnetfeldern beeinflusst.
Das können wir schlecht beobachten,
wenn wir
unseren Kühlschrank-Magneten nehmen.
Aber wir können mit Elektromagneten
stärkere Magnetfelder erzeugen.
Jeder Stromfluss
erzeugt ein Magnetfeld.
Wo Strom fließt,
ist ein elektrisches Feld.
Und das beeinflusst
alle geladenen Teilchen.
In unserer realen Welt wirken
elektrische Felder auf alle Atome.
Denn die bestehen zum Großteil
aus Protonen und Elektronen.
Auf mikroskopisch kleiner Ebene
ist Elektromagnetismus
für viele Phänomene verantwortlich:
dass Eis gefriert,
wie Mineralien sich formen,
wie Feuer aussieht oder Luft strömt.
Wenn der Avatar
elektromagnetische Felder
erzeugen und kontrollieren kann,
kann er auch die Elemente bändigen.
Danke, Anne.
Mit elektromagnetischen Feldern
kann man coole Sachen machen.
Dass das für uns hilfreich sein kann,
möchte ich euch zeigen.
Hier haben die Kollegen
vom YouTube-Kanal "Veritasium"
mit starken Feldern
nicht nur eine 100-Kilo-Aluplatte
zum Schweben gebracht.
(auf Englisch) Toll!
Die haben es auch noch geschafft,
dass ein elektrischer Kerzenleuchter
in der Nähe der Felder angeht.
Das ist cool
und sieht krass nach Bändigen aus.
Ja, aber lass uns mal schauen,
was das für die Elemente bedeutet.
Machen wir und starten
mit dem Element der Substanz ...
... Erde.
*Donner und Trommelmusik*
Erdbändiger können Erde,
aber auch Gesteinsbrocken hochheben.
Sie können die verformen und bewegen,
wie die wollen.
Ja, wobei es
noch Unter-Bändigungsarten gibt,
also Unterarten des Erdbändigens.
Z.B. Schlammbändigen,
Sandbändigen,
Keramikbändigen, Glasbändigen, usw.
Das ergibt Sinn.
Erde besteht zum Großteil
aus mineralischen Bestandteilen.
Sand und Schlamm bändigen
ergibt total Sinn.
Auf jeden Fall.
Auch der Autor einer Spin-off-Serie
hat in einem Interview gemeint,
dass Erdbändiger
alles manipulieren können,
was Mineralien beinhaltet.
Steine und Erde sind der Standard.
Und dann gibt es Unterarten,
die entstanden sind,
weil die Erdbändiger
sich ihrer Umgebung angepasst haben.
Oder weil sie Dinge benötigen,
die härtere Ausdauer benötigen.
Wie das Metallbändigen.
Metall bändigen?
Okay, das ist krasser als nur Erde.
Was, würdest du sagen,
ist die krasseste Erdbändigungs-Form?
Lava bändigen auf jeden Fall.
Das ist das seltenste.
- Klingt auf jeden Fall gefährlich.
Lass uns das rückbeziehen auf das,
was Anne gesagt hat.
Anne hat gesagt:
Wir brauchen zum Bändigen
elektromagnetische Felder.
Anne, was bedeutet das
fürs Erdbändigen?
In unserer Erde ist auch Metall.
Deswegen ist es naheliegend,
dass Erdbändiger
v.a. mit Magnetismus arbeiten.
Wenn dem so wäre,
wäre Metallbändigen viel leichter
als das Bändigen von Erde und Stein.
Das ist in der Serie andersherum.
Deswegen lasst uns konzentrieren
auf elektrische Felder.
Die Theorie ist,
dass Erdbändiger
so starke Felder erzeugen,
dass sie negativ geladene Teilchen
tiefer in die Erde drücken
und oben positiv geladene Erde
zurückbleibt.
Wenn sie
das elektrische Feld ändern,
können sie es zu sich heranziehen
oder abstoßen und wegschleudern.
Das erklärt,
warum Erdbändigen einfacher ist
als Metallbändigen.
In Erde ist es einfacher,
den Grundzustand
von getrennten Ladungen zu halten
als in Metall.
Weil Erde schlecht leitet
und Metall sehr gut.
In Metall fließen freie Elektronen
leichter zurück als in Erde.
Für den Bändiger
bedeutet das bei Metall:
Er muss konstant dafür sorgen,
dass die Elektronen bleiben,
wo sie sind.
Lava ist geschmolzene Erde.
Deswegen funktioniert Lavabändigen
nach dem gleichen Prinzip.
Wir haben gesagt:
Erde leitet schlecht.
Im Umkehrschluss heißt das:
Der Widerstand in Erde ist groß.
Wie bei einem Widerstand,
den ich in den Schaltkreis einbaue,
bedeutet das für die Erde,
dass sie warm wird bei Stromfluss.
Wenn das elektrische Feld
groß genug ist,
kann sie so heiß werden,
dass aus ihr Lava wird.
Das passt dazu,
dass Lavabändigen selten ist.
Denn wir brauchen stärkere Felder,
um Lava zu bändigen,
als um Erde zu bändigen.
Okay, das klingt so,
als müssten die Bändiger
sich hart konzentrieren,
damit das funktioniert
und viel Energie aufbringen.
Total, und über eines
haben wir nicht gesprochen:
Einige Bändiger verfügen
über den "seismischen Sinn".
Sie können durch Vibrationen spüren,
wo sich Feinde befinden.
Ähnlich wie Toph.
- Okay.
Das würde passen zur Erklärung,
die Anne gegeben hat.
Wenn man es nicht über Vibrationen,
sondern elektrische Felder macht.
Sie kontrollieren die
und würden mitkriegen,
wenn eine Person in das Feld tritt
und damit wechselwirkt.
Das haben wir schon besprochen,
in unserer Folge
zu den "Fantastischen Tierwesen".
Da ging es um das Schnabeltier,
das seine Beute ähnlich wittert.
Die haben
Elektrorezeptoren im Schnabel
und kriegen dadurch mit,
wo sich ein Beutetier befindet.
Von daher können wir sagen:
Der seismische Sinn aus der Serie
passt auch mit unserem Konzept
vom Elektromagnetismus gut zusammen.
*Donner und Trommelmusik*
Die Luftbändiger haben für mich
die spannendste Geschichte der Serie,
denn die sind nah an der echten Welt.
Zumindest sind sie
von tibetanischen Mönchen inspiriert.
Sowohl im Aussehen
als auch
im Ausleben ihrer Spiritualität.
Dadurch, dass sie vom Hinduismus
und Buddhismus inspiriert wurden,
sollten sie genau das verkörpern
und waren "das Gute" in der Serie.
Leider muss ich
in der Vergangenheit reden,
da die Feuernation
die Luftnomaden ausgerottet hat.
Mit Ausnahme von Aang,
"the last airbender",
also der letzte Luftbändiger.
Er hat krasse Fähigkeiten:
auf Tornados, Druckwellen
und seinem Luftroller fliegen, usw.
Das sieht sehr cool aus.
Das mit dem Luftroller
finde ich skurril.
Wie das jetzt
mit Elektromagnetismus zusammenhängt,
kann ich mir nicht ganz vorstellen,
aber dafür haben wir ja Anne.
Lasst uns dafür
über ionischen Wind sprechen.
Der entsteht,
wenn ein Objekt
mit starkem elektrischen Feld
geladene Teilchen
in der Luft abstößt.
Diese Teilchen
stoßen mit neutralen zusammen
und klauen denen die Elektronen.
So entsteht eine Kettenreaktion,
die man "Corona-Entladung"
oder "Elektronen-Lawine" nennt.
Wenn der Luftbändiger
mit einem elektrischen Feld
genug Teilchen kontrollieren kann,
kann er den ionischen Wind steuern
und komplexe Strömungsmuster
erschaffen.
Das klingt nach Science Fiction,
ist es aber nicht.
Forschende vom MIT
haben 2018
ein Leichtflugzeug gebaut,
das das nutzt
und mit "Ionenantrieb" fliegt.
Sieht aus wie ein normales Flugzeug,
aber unter den Flügeln
sind Hochspannungs-Elektroden.
Vorne ist Draht
und dahinter eine Tragfläche.
Am Draht liegt
eine Spannung von 20.000 Volt an.
Das ist so stark,
dass Stickstoff-Moleküle
ionisiert werden.
An der Tragfläche
sind minus 20.000 Volt.
So entsteht ein elektrisches Feld
zwischen Draht und Tragfläche.
Die Stickstoff-Ionen
werden im Feld beschleunigt.
Sie ziehen neutrale Luftionen mit,
und es entsteht ionischer Wind,
der das Flugzeug antreibt.
Genau das
können wir jetzt hier nachmachen.
Fabi, willkommen
in unserem Experimente-Setting.
Sieht alles super crazy aus.
Hast du ein bisschen Schiss?
Geht, du?
- Ja, tatsächlich doch.
Alles, was mit Strom ist,
lassen wir lieber Leute machen,
die sich auskennen.
Die haben wir eingeladen.
Matthias ist da.
Vielen Dank fürs Unterstützen.
Matthias hat
ein Hochspannungs-Netzgerät dabei.
Mit dem können wir das machen,
was Anne gerade erklärt hat.
Nämlich hohe Spannung
im Bereich von 20.000 Volt erzeugen.
Hier oben ist der Pluspol.
An den Drähten ist der Minuspol.
Das Ufo, das wir gebaut haben,
wird nicht über den Faden gezogen,
sondern da liegt Spannung an.
Die Drähte
sind mit der Alufolie verbunden.
Das sind unsere Tragflächen.
Das, was im Leichtflugzeug vom MIT
die Tragfläche ist,
ist hier die Alufolie.
Wenn wir die Hochspannung anlegen,
sollte durch den ionischen Wind
dieses Ufo hier abheben.
Dafür müssen wir
noch die Kerze anmachen.
Fabi, das kannst du machen.
- Ja, mal schauen, was passiert.
Wenn dieser Wind entsteht,
sollte unsere Kerze anfangen,
ordentlich zu flackern.
Das ist der Indikator,
dass es funktioniert.
Bist du bereit?
- Ich bin ready, es geht los.
Let's do it.
Matthias, los.
*spannende Musik*
Luftbändigen.
Wir kommen.
Oh, oh, okay.
Das ist noch ein Lehrling.
- Aber jetzt.
Pass auf, oh!
Yes, sehr cool.
Er schwebt.
- Und die Kerze, guck.
*Jack lacht.*
Alter, nice!
Krass.
Irre, oder?
Und hörst du das Surren?
Du merkst auf jeden Fall,
dass mit Strom experimentiert wird.
Okay, also können wir festhalten:
So könnte Luftbändigen funktionieren.
Ja, und es erklärt,
warum Luftbändiger
so springen können
und dann wieder
so langsam landen können.
Wenn sie das kontrollieren können,
ist das kein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
*spannende Musik*
Am coolsten ist das Fliegen,
egal, ob mit oder ohne Gleiter,
auf Luftrollern
oder ohne Hilfsmittel.
Wobei, am coolsten und bequemsten
natürlich auf Appa.
Das ist das fliegende Bison, richtig?
Genau, die ursprünglichen Bändiger
wiegen gern mal 10 t.
Deswegen stelle ich
es mir schwierig vor,
dass sie so gechillt fliegen können,
wie es gezeigt wurde.
Stimmt, Gewicht spielt eine Rolle.
Aber eine Boeing 737 hebt auch ab
und bringt locker 80 t auf die Waage.
Wenn du sagst,
die Bisons
sind die ursprünglichen Bändiger,
dann können die
eine so krasse Strömung erzeugen,
dass genug Auftrieb
zum Abheben entsteht.
Dann müsste es funktionieren.
Wir nehmen uns so ein Bison
und halten es uns als Haustier.
Ja, das wäre auf jeden Fall
das coolste Haustier aller Zeiten.
*Krächzen*
Das war ein wilder Ritt
auf unserem wissenschaftlichen Bison
durch die Welt von "Avatar".
Erde und Luft haben wir schon.
Nächste Woche
sind Wasser und Feuer an der Reihe.
Heiß.
*zischendes Surren*
Auf jeden Fall.
Und wenn ihr Zweifel habt und denkt,
das mit dem Elektromagnetismus
sei Quatsch:
Nächste Woche
gibt es weitere Erklärungen.
Und Fabi, du bist auch dabei?
- Bin dabei.
Dafür hast du dir viel Liebe
von unserer Community verdient.
Also flitzt rüber zu Fabis Kanal.
Abonnieren, liken und kommentieren.
Das Gleiche
könnt ihr auch bei uns machen.
Also auch diesen Kanal ...
... abonnieren.
- Und ...
... Glocke aktivieren.
Wir sehen uns in einer Woche wieder!
- Ciao!
Wenn ihr nicht genug bekommen könnt
von "Avatar",
dann klickt hier oben.
Noch mehr animierte Action
gibt es hier mit One Punch Man.
Copyright MDR 2022